in imouth harbor vessels
tied up are a visual metaphor for their
industry
post brexit getting their product
overseas
isn't what it used to be
a third of scotland's fishing boats are
going nowhere for now
for rope read red tape i have to say
they're letting us down badly
badly james cook isn't happy with the uk
government's brexit preparations
he's a middle man in the fishing
industry fishermen sell prawns like
these to him
and he sells them onto the continent but
the prawns along with the lobsters are
being kept in tanks for now
because new procedures mean getting them
across the channel
is proving impossible basically
paperwork it's actually accessing the
customs documentation we've been through
about 11 customs agents
you know the clearers that can can do
some of the components of the job but
they can't do the whole thing so
it's very very frustrating industry
leaders
are warning that as bad as things are
now there is a long-term danger
the business will simply go elsewhere
already some fishing boats are landing
their product in denmark as an easier
alternative
to reaching the continental market that
cuts out
the processing industry in scotland
which employs ten thousand people
the seafood industry is calling for a
six-month period of grace on paperwork
from the uk and eu
and for firms losing hundreds of
thousands of pounds it wants adequate
compensation
on the blockages of brexit business
isn't seeing the funny side and the key
is we've got our fish back they're now
british fish
and they're better and happier fish for
it
well i think that sums up what the
government really thinks about or how
they understand the problem
industry views on westminster are
passive
and aggressive prime minister and
michael gove
i can assure you if scottish exporters
can't get their product to market next
week
we will be at the gates of westminster
and we'll be dumping our shellfish
on your doorstep rotten
on brexit's complications the tide needs
to turn
and quickly time pressure on its
transport
has put seafood in the first wave to hit
the wall
it won't be the last james matthews
sky news in imouth